[Music]
one of the great things that culture and
art is capable of is actually giving a
physical length which is something that
is otherwise highly mediated or abstract
meaning that something like climate
change it's very difficult to understand
because he says I can't touch it I can't
measure it it's not like it it's not
like a ball in my hand it was actually
for the first time possible to sail the
North West Poisson side of the North
Pole connecting to oceans and shortening
the way of sailing and it's been long
time debated whether this will ever ever
be possible and now with global warming
and the melting of the ice it suddenly
is possible and in that sense I thought
this is a nice topic I'm interested in
and the fact that when you see said like
the pictures off of the ocean airplane
picture sort of this particular ocean
you see the ice scattered around and you
realize that these white ice sheets they
look like small islands or small pieces
of land and even if you wanted to cross
you have to jump from one to the other
and that have interested me I'd actually
made drawings of that in my studio and I
was just interested in the fact that a
lot of what we know as being stable has
become unstable and a lot of the things
that we take for granted is out of the
reach of change are in fact now change
he said the world as we know it has
become a lot more relative and with
regards to the whole sort of idea of
next nanotechnology I thought okay this
is also interesting because in a way
nano is about making what we could not
see before visible or making the
invisible visible
as an artist I'm trying to sort out well
what kind of art or what type of
artistic interventions in the world can
I do to bring about a more action driven
relationship with the climate or an
opportunity for you to see well turning
your knowledge into action is actually
something that is a little easier than I
thought it would be and actually the
climate is not as abstract as I thought
it'd be it's right here in front of me I
can touch it and it is understandable
and it's not like big science it's quite
specific and and so on I think that
other loans should not be the one who
communicates the explicit Fayed version
of what Clara challenges but it is one
of the great things that I think is
exciting to work with as an artist this
is to make things which we know explicit
as something as we feel giving it out
you could call it emotional narrative
besides this sort of data table data
driven narrative the other here came out
of my interest in various other artworks
to work with geometry and these small
random shapes days you say these so
puddles of pools ice sheets and I'm
actually in this case particularly
interested in the fact when you look up
your verges you obviously see the
reflection of the ground because it's a
mirror and you look up and you see on
the ground
and to that extent it is actually like a
ceiling which which has these small
islands if you want off the ground and
I've worked with that a few times but
you could also see them as stepping
stones should we be in a situation where
the South Pole meds and the chances are
significant but it's not just some crazy
idea it's actually is that probably
means that half of Boston is completely
underwater not just a little bit like
literally underwater going around and
the campus is likely to be jumping from
one stepping stone to the other so when
I talk about these things I talk about
the kind of way that a space contains
not just us
but also our action and our ability to
interact and to share things and I think
art can be a part of that equation and
artistic interventions and amplify what
makes this fit the space better amplify
the fact that we should be open-minded
to the extent of understanding that
spaces actually have social potential as
well
sometimes you need a language so you
need a sofa equality in a space which
simply triggers that sort of social or
that generous type of activity
[Music]
you
[Music]